[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka a friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and with far
from home putting the world in a spin
the web has just received reports on
what the original ending for the film
was supposed to be throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the alternate
scenes as well as why they were changed
for the final cut there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't seen far
from home yet and don't want anything
ruined then I highly suggest that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into my
breakdown of the alternate ending for
far from home okay so in the original
ending of spider-man far from home
Mysterio is revealed to be a disgruntled
ex-employee of Tony Stark who along with
others has been trying to get access to
his tech early in the film Peter who
doubts his own abilities hands over the
Edith glasses which grab the wearer
access to stocks Arsenal and with these
now in the clutches of Mysterio he is
able to launch a massive attack on Tower
Bridge Peter rushes there manages to
defeat Mysterio who seemingly dies
though don't believe everything you see
on the internet and he returns home
after saving the day and getting the
girl of his dreams
Peter swings through the city with MJ
and all seems great until a live
broadcast of fake news from the Daily
Bugle net reveals that Mysterio or one
of his cohorts has created some fake
footage that shows he launched the
attack on Tower Bridge as another gut
punch from beyond the grave
spider-man's identity is revealed as
Peter Parker which yeah what a
cliffhanger whilst we cut to black this
scene actually played out a lot
differently in the original ending of
the film with the writers though coming
to the same conclusion
revealing Peters identity to the world
in a different way when speaking to the
New York Times recently co-write as Eric
summers and Chris McKenna stated that
initially Peters identity reveal was
going to be part of the final act of the
movie instead of just part of the
post-credits scene in the interview they
stated with Mysterio there were versions
of the story where he was at the
forefront as an out-and-out villain that
Peter and Nick were chasing around
Europe as he pulled off these events
this was all building to this backstory
of why he was doing it which was a
wholly different third act we went down
a lot of different roads and ultimately
because Mysterio deals so much in
deception it was sort of natural and it
led to a story structure where his
entire identity was a mislead for a
while we were challenged by the
producers to come up with something that
Peter sacrifices by the end of this
movie and when we hit upon that as a
group it became a very scary idea it's
such a bold maneuver that it became
inevitable particularly with a tricky
character like Mysterio who's this dark
father figure from the grave is he
trying to give Peter his I'm Iron Man
moment it's thrust upon him but is this
a lesson or a punishment we played with
the idea that Peter is the one who
sacrifices his identity out of necessity
during the final battle then it seemed
more interesting if Mysterio tricks him
into doing it but anytime we wrote a
version where he was being revealed for
the world in that battle it felt like it
diminished the victory before it became
a tag it was really just the end of the
movie right as he feels like he's
stepping up his spider-man he has the
rug pulled out from under him again so
it seems like Mysterio was going to use
Peter being gullible again to reveal who
he was similar for the scene earlier in
the movie where he accidentally gave up
Ned and MJ's identity de Becque during
the skyscraper fight
what really hits home with me is that
they talk about Peter sacrificing his
identity out of necessity which could
have meant that Mysterio held some of
Peters friends hostage and therefore
forced him to reveal who he was of the
world in order to save their lives
whilst I think this would have been cool
to see I definitely think the
post-credits scenes stinger works a lot
better as not only does a compromised
peter's identity it also sets him up as
a target for both heroes and villains as
the world will believe that he killed
Mysterio and has been orchestrating the
attacks the fact that he has edith of
course gives him access to this and many
will no doubt worry that he now has too
much power especially for his age which
of course sets of civil war to
potentially with Captain Marvel trying
to take this back personally I think the
ending that we got works a lot better
and
easy to see why I've made it to the
final cut as this original ending allows
Peter to become the hero which is no
doubt not what Mysterio wanted
hence the reveal in addition to this it
was also some discussion over the
post-credits scene and getting JK
Simmons involved in which the writers
said there had already been some
interest and possibly using JK Simmons
when we brought JJ on her back
so once it was decided that we were
going to reveal his identity at the very
end instead of the final battle it all
fell into place very naturally at J
Jonah would be involved something that
had been floating around through this
entire movie was the idea of fake news
and how you can believe everything we
see we had been toying with that idea
that Mysterio would turn spider-man into
a villain just like he did in the comic
books and I felt like that then tied
into this J Jonah 2.0 as the Alex Jones
of the MCU originally Nick Fury and
Maria Hill were not scrolls either
however the writers felt that it would
be a disservice to fury to have him
tricked by an illusionist when he's
supposed to be one of the world's most
cunning spies overall I definitely think
the changes work a lot better and the
film really got me hooked on to what
could come down the line it was a smart
move for the film to play out the way it
did and I really can't wait to see
what's next for the webhead
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and if you would have
preferred the original ending or not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of everything that we know so far about
the Marvel San Diego Comic Con face for
panel it goes over all of the upcoming
movies and it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
I'll leave that linked at the end and
hopefully I'll see you over there after
this I also just want to let you know
that we're giving away a free copy of
Avengers endgame on blu-ray to one lucky
winner and all you have to do is like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on the movie in the comments section
below
the winner will be chosen at random and
August the 10th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from the end whoever gets
the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again to take the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]